unfortunately we begin with breaking
news on a shooting in new mexico
involving actor alec baldwin
sheriffs say that one person was killed
and another was injured when baldwin
fired a prop gun on a movie set he has
not been charged with a crime he was
questioned after yesterday's shooting
and then he was released the movie
cinematographer 42-year-old helena
hutchins died in this incident director
joel souza was treated at a hospital for
unspecified injuries jonathan bigliotti
is following this story jonathan we saw
pictures of alec baldwin he's very
distraught we're here good morning and
good morning to you that's correct a
tragedy and still a mystery according to
baldwin spokesperson the accident
occurred when a prop gun with blanks
misfired sheriffs confirmed the
63-year-old actor was the person who
fired the gun how a movie prop became a
deadly weapon is still under
investigation this morning
this is the set of the western rust
thursday afternoon the scene of the
incident marked off by police tape
alec baldwin is not only the star but
also the movie's co-producer that
morning he posted this now deleted
instagram photo of himself in costume
with the caption back to in person at
the office
just hours later he was questioned by
sheriffs after shooting a prop gun that
injured the film's director joel souza
and killed director of photography
helena hutchins
on tuesday hutchins posted this video
saying one of the perks of shooting a
western is you get to ride horses on
your day off
sheriffs say she was airlifted to a
hospital where she was pronounced dead
souza was also taken to a hospital
the circumstances of the incident are
under investigation according to movie
set gun safety expert larry zanoff a gun
loaded with blanks has gun powder but
should have no projectiles still he says
it's potentially dangerous to be within
20 feet of a prop gun when fired any of
that smoke or powder or that muzzle
flash that could affect anyone or
anything
again we keep a standoff distance of 20
feet in order for there to be no effect
on something that's in front of the
muzzle
in 1993 actor brandon lee was killed on
a movie set when he was shot with a gun
supposedly loaded with blanks an autopsy
later revealed he was shot by a bullet
and in 1984 actor john eric hexham died
after he fired a prop magnum 44 with
blanks at his head in a mock game of
russian roulette we're always concerned
with safety on a television and
motion picture set and that's why
there's guidelines to follow
and detectives are now investigating how
firing the prop gun resulted in death
and injury and they're continuing to
interview witnesses production meanwhile
on the film has been halted gail
all right jonathan such a tragic tragic
accident thank you so much my first
thought when i heard it number one it
was i thought i was reading it wrong at
first when i read it i thought about
helena hutchins of course and her family
does she have a partner does she have
children it's so tragic and the director
and then my heart goes out to alec
baldwin clearly was an accident you see
him doubled over in pain how you have to
now he has to live with this it's just
an awful situation for everybody
involved yeah we know it's rare but it
does happen the unfortunate thing about
this tragedy is that it could have been
avoided
yeah it would seem so miss hutchins had
been a journalist in europe had been
made a career transition to film seem to
have a bright future ahead it's a big
tragedy big loss